you'd be surprised the number of
actually San Franciscans like actually
live in the city but buy and own
firearms but their backgrounds going to
wear from like their medium blue collar
to six figures it's everyone Stephen L
Cairo is the general manager of
Highbridge arms which is San Francisco's
very last gun store well it's been here
for a very long time it's been here I
remember it as a kid to me it's like a
hardware store Highbridge Arms was
opened in 1952 by the renowned Olympic
shooter Bob Chow and it hasn't changed
much since then the stores located on a
commercial strip in the Bernal Heights
neighborhood and it blends in well with
the surrounding businesses but now the
store is closing its doors in large part
because of a local law that's making it
impossible to do business security has
been tight at Highbridge arms for years
we have motion sensors here we have 17
cameras that are visible to the public
on the property and several that are
concealed and these are things that
we've already done with the police
department we're the only shop in San
Francisco we obviously have to
communicate and cooperate with them get
in July
mark Farrell a member of the San
Francisco Board of Supervisors back to
local ordinance that would force the
store to go even farther
the latest gun control proposal before
the San Francisco Board of Supervisors
demands that every gun transaction be
recorded and sent to SFPD for those that
think that gun control doesn't work I
have a significant disagreement with
that I'll cairo says that as soon as the
lowest proposed business suffered we
were getting a bunch of phone calls
asking about it
the big concern customer privacy as a
consumer coming in here and I knew that
the shopkeepers would then submit that
information to the police department I
probably wouldn't shop here but I
purchased a firearm personally I
realizes there's a federal and state
Department of Justice requirements that
are mandated for that I'm willing to do
that but just the idea of giving that
information willingly
to the police department for no real
reason is seems very unreasonable with
business suffering so much before the
ordinance even passed high bridges
managers decided to finally close the
store after 63 years we discussed it and
we felt it was probably in our better
interest to just finally hang it up some
locals are cheering the stores closing
they think it'll make the city safer
without the gun store while Kyra says it
won't change a thing other than to take
choices away from his law-abiding
customers that guys are still going to
get guns no matter how many stores he
closed down I wouldn't like it if San
Francisco take a look at this
we decriminalized Medical Marijuana you
know we pioneered equal rights I mean
but in the same town you're gearing laws
specifically to make it hard on me